black people are going to save America  from Joe Biden  you think so  okay we got tricked he's weakened at  Bernie's bro  you literally re-upped on the most  racist practice in America gun control  as the black people started buying more  guns than ever you said we're going to  send you to jail for 10 years  fortunately the Supreme Court was like  what you are bugging you speak to black  people as if you literally own them if  you don't vote for me you ain't black  what type of [ __ ] it's amazing yeah  it's the level of entitlement and  audacity mind you you're the same guy  that crafted the criminal legislation  criminal to send many of these black men  to jail in the first place black people  are gonna have to save America from Joe  Biden  then black people are going to have to  become Libertarians and save America  from  America